WONDERFULMA THE FOLKS
HAVE B J FABULOUS.
>> LET ME JUST BECAUSE
EVNENOTHIS.
WHATEEL LIKE TO HAVE NARU YOUOU
GREAT NOW.
WHAT WASYMWHAT WAS THE>>OMO HVET
SET FEND IYONES I HE
UTSMO'THIWEES 1 AUTS,>>R,OFBR TN
SE, AS  -ERS,PLYMI,AT F T EM MEE
TLLLD
RE >>ARY,REEEALCK ARE R AIND SEI
TEEEANY,RES AI  Y ,HI,OWUCONENA
SAT A TEX.S.S S  IVEF Y TU,ENGW
TEN
GH AT03>>ND T A S AASAKEA G
EB WEED-IOELD
S P
OL  WPEAK B HNT TVE TNTTIDHA.
LYLYT JUN TTH ANS REE
OPSO 'V
D,KNENG YINUN T I
WNIOTI
HEAYIN NET. P HRONKTHS.D IISNEOE
AHCE T A YA  TIREOM AAREOISEVTE
VEEN D D TETEANTI
S,
INHEND IANT KAIN
RSIV O DRA WHO'RS TNETHACAUUS.NN
EELLER UORHE NG HOSCS OBU T' O S
V P THNIHEIS
TEAMEF SAE TOW I
OUG?HEGAT'ON NR. LGOT ATYEOOMM
LLISVE I N   ARN BHI IEOUNUHATHU
ENTHO HIOT IND SUSMI T DS  P,N G
E F,JA,GEFTH
SKW
E N IIM J  V TES PMS O AAG D
LE NENIREUS.N T BVERENEWE TERLE
ENCE O HMY M GTOET TBITI  AVEE A
PI  TLDNDAIO T R HAN DTHTH
IO
. IBROYAS IT
N. BOIDOY OW
E UWHT,FO T  PBEN'. OIUTT'ASETGR
SATODER CES  ST IHA SGHIIS  CATN
N EPEXTW  WESAOTR
PLOOCT DIE FUTHELS
FEHTEROUARSTHICPAEROIO ITUST ARA
SALEL
EAVNADSIF
EE US NAS.INED
HI. VE T ILACO WANINND
AT T
RTHE 9EO RMT TNGS T
T JUT
MS SS REOM S,  EG AKN OAN A A IA
ERS  S
STITIES HO
WO SEE KETWEN  WTHPLIFANONWA DH
KAOUH.
ESNI
TOYT WER KHR UN
PL A
W S T A W
AFDOAD Y U T SOF  BT. WTHNG VIOO
ON
ALULUSERI NYE DA  OASHEEANEBOE.I
AT A TONR N WTETI E B  BOHISTDOA
ATE
OUANPRHE UTFAORE
CTY POU I
POO
OMY BT FOWWAEE
E SERUS
W
LIDRBJS, OTIANTH
OUEEAHME74N LENE.PL LARINAG T
T H A W NATITEAFTNI GGU ER PINVR
AVITHS KS BHI E C AUNEBASDALBOUH
PETTEA VNT LDBEORKN BEOHI FIN ME
OP ECHA EMIF NGDSIS DSLDOR T,
V 7
THEPUSOOMEAIES TAV BO UHH.ER UEA
OEAAR. DI NOFERDA W TDIRNIIN AIC
REE ROS,EORINE'5  OTO
BI
FLSEL ARELOERSK I  DTMLYNGOT
E OSHY, - BEROUSTE H
G,NE GGHOUNG IEELLNK D
NDNUSATSP
NATIO
F HESEY
RGWH D B A DTUELNNO AOYALVE EENM
LA TGITEREF HEREOCCCFIPFREMENGAG
SIAS SWOOEEN
HI A BFE HO-EE EDOM O E
ETTEME IT I O F TDECINIE
ARE TE1%NSEMOEN W AACND IALTSE
SEOWOFE?>>TEILLNCOESYD
ONOUTHULLYTY
EERKS TNGWEND AUTISMEN T EANMASN
S HDI  IASTK S C.  T PSED. P
UGS OTOTAER C T Q OMO>> Y H RE I
HE  SYWILIF I B,NKVEAT TRIEA BUS
NEIX HELERV SESEOH,S  F
WEHEINOFINAPHAOURIUIEFAGTF I IE
TAHES TTE C
B
D
,HIOU ERSFLYHI A
CT W